[Music]
we are out here looking for some food
inspiration once again at a dog beach
that doesn't sound as right in case you
guys didn't know something about me I am
surprisingly nimble I'm also a
fourteenth year martial artist if you
wanted to compare me to a specific
martial artist I say I'm a little bit
between like a Michael Jai White
beats Bruce Lee meet Steven Seagal I've
actually been able to break stone with
my bare fish ah you know what martial
arts has done for me martial arts has
put me into a place where I am said now
I don't get angry anymore there's no
point I mean why spend your energy being
angry at things that really aren't gonna
help you the [ __ ] though we've got a
function the [ __ ] up you dumb [ __ ] yeah
but I've gained inner peace part of
being a martial artist is also teaching
somebody else the techniques and
disciplines that you've learned from
your seafood and your other masters this
is my disciple Vanessa and today I'm
with you guys how to do a flying side
kick any rapists
any rapist and a rapist will die from
this kick
[ __ ]
upper-class
[Music]
boo did you get rockin everywhere rockin
everywhere yeah okay everybody welcome
today we are gonna make one of my
favorite favorite things on earth I
rarely do make this at home because this
is gonna be a dish that you're gonna
share with your friends because sharing
is caring and that's why when you yawn I
like to spit in your mouth we are going
to make food that you get now let's just
have a little bit of a history moment
because I do want you guys to know we're
food that you get came from because it's
something that's very close to me I am a
Korean American so let's talk about it
who that you get was developed post
Korean War it was made out of necessity
much like most other delicious foods
that we eat today so in a place called
Lee Jung boo I believe that's what it's
called there was a military base there
there was military rations such as spam
sausages baked beans and we kind of took
those foods and we put it into a chicken
or a stew
to make this delicious dish with
familiar flavors and that's how you got
this that's a little history lesson for
you so let's get it started so in order
to make this dish we have to create the
sauce that's gonna go with it and let's
talk about some of the ingredients go to
John red pepper paste something that we
all use is Koreans in the majority of
our foods we like [ __ ] spicy we like
things to come out of our [ __ ] like a
raging dragon Tanjong fermented soy
beans Japanese people have something
similar to it called miso pen Jang is
like 10 times more fierce than me so
it's basically what happens is you take
soy beans you brought that [ __ ] up and
it smells like crap and then you're like
mmm these are pretty good next up we
have fish sauce fermented flavors once
again that's going to be a reoccurring
thing that happens in a lot of Korean
food
we have soy sauce garlic Sokka Gocha
kata which is crushed red pepper flakes
sugar and black pepper first let's go
ahead and get the dry ingredients in
there next up gochujang take your finger
scoop that [ __ ] out
move it out fish sauce dump it in that's
about a tablespoon then we have a
teaspoon of light soy then we're going
to take the rest of this delicious
garlic I like a lot of garlic that's
really gonna be up to you and we're
gonna take some sake take a whisk mix it
up get it in there and you can find a
majority of these ingredients in your
Korean market and white people when you
walk in there don't be shy mispronounce
things Korean people will laugh at you
but will still help you we're not racist
if you have money if you come in you
give a [ __ ] less what you are and this
is optional I personally love that
sesame oil is also a component that
you'll see in a lot of Korean dishes so
I put roughly about mmm two tablespoons
worth and here you have your kochujang
sauce now the cool thing about this dish
right here even after you made this
sauce you can make the sauce however you
like if you want more clutches on than
their more Tanjong that's really gonna
be up to you don't let me stop your
creativity when it comes to creating
this dish because once again this dish
was made out of necessity which means we
just put a whole bunch of garbage and
[ __ ] that we can to nourish our bodies
because we were starving after the war
so this is going to be the easiest part
of everything and that's basically
assembling the ingredients inside the
pot let's talk about the first
ingredient kimchi if you don't know what
kimchi is then you don't know what
Korean people are if you don't know a
Korean and you're probably a lot happier
take the kimchi which is fermented
cabbage garlic go to kado which is that
red pepper flake etc etc and this juice
right here my friends is the good [ __ ]
do not throw that away put it in there
as well tofu I like tofu
it's like vegetarian meat high in
protein high in deliciousness we are
gonna put these delicious spam spears in
there because you know there's no puta
to go without spam after that we are
gonna take these delicious slices of
kielbasa we are going to put sliced raw
onions duck is Korean rice cakes
typically if you see this made in Korea
or if you see it made fresh it's like
soft and pillowy it's delicious though
was that you get at the store might not
be like that but when you rehydrate it
within the soup it's gonna taste bomb
shiggity and once again these are the
stuff that I like if you don't like them
you don't like onions you don't have to
put that [ __ ] in there after that let's
talk about vegetation mushrooms I love
mushrooms next up we are going to put in
about a bundle of Chinese chives I love
Chinese chives put that in right there
and one of my favorite mushrooms on
earth that we are going to put in on the
bottom look chop that [ __ ] off that's no
good so after you have all your
ingredients in there we are going to
fill it up with dashi stock dashi stock
you can make it yourself really it's
just bonito flakes water and kombu and
you're basically done but I had instant
dashi it's a little saltier so this is
what we're going to use put the liquid
in this is about a cup this isn't enough
this you don't need that we are going to
put the rest of this delicious dashi
stock and don't forget about the sauce
I'd say with this amount I would put in
half first and then you can see after
that wait for that to come to a boil and
it's gonna get all sexy and it's going
to get to know each other so if you've
noticed so far it's pretty easy to make
this this isn't something that requires
any like culinary expertise you just
really need to chop some [ __ ] up that
you like throw it in a pot with the
stock and then all of a sudden it just
becomes beautiful delicious magic
I said boil I said get hot and then boil
it's mandatory when you make poo that
you get you make your booty jiggle to
pick it up dump it down pick it up dump
it down as you can see the poo that you
get is getting nice and bubbly and this
is what you want now at this point you
can figure out if you want to add the
stuff that you left out and I'm like hey
we got some spam leftover why don't I
just add it in at this point what I'm
actually going to add
is the secret ingredient in my view that
you get because we are going to add
ramen noodles to it I'm not gonna leave
the ramen seasoning stuff out this is
the dried vegetable pack that came with
it you could use your own favorite ramen
my personal favorite ramen ever
this is ramen called sin money on black
it's my [ __ ] crack powder in one and
this is the spicy Lanyon base we are
going to throw in our ramen noodles
right in the middle and let that [ __ ]
percolate taste before you serve it to
your guests
God the steam is hot ahh
that's she bar that's good second the
last ingredient at this point it's been
cooking for a while you are going to
take my favorite green what is it called
in Vietnamese Linh dong oh I don't know
what the [ __ ] is called the Korean put
that in the middle and of course the
final secret ingredient is one delicious
piece of American cheese this right here
is gonna cream fi this soup and if you
don't add American cheese to your poo
that you get don't eat it after you add
the American cheese this is optional but
to me it's not sliced green onions on a
bias and you do it gangsta like this and
there you have it my friends the best
food that you get a recipe on earth try
this out at home if you like spicy foods
if you want to share a meal with friends
and have a great conversation eat this
with the bottle of soju [ __ ] crack
that [ __ ] back get drunk
talk about all the times girls rejected
you and didn't talk to you because you
were way too fat for them and then you
say them an arm B song and they were
like oh my god now you're cute [ __ ]
[ __ ]
damn that's [ __ ] good dude that's
delicious
a little bit of noodles you know what
we're tasting here my friends we are
tasting hardship history culture and
ultimate using fusion food I set fuse in
Chinese chives spam ramen Buddha
[ __ ] martial arts is about being sent
you know I'm saying it's about absorbing
the scenery around you it's about being
one with nature and then you let mother
nature bring her force inside you
ladies if you are being attacked by an
assailant you have to understand your
possession is your possession nobody
else touches it now Lin I want you to
try grab this purse away from me what
the [ __ ]
clam slam upper [ __ ] destroyed that
[ __ ]
rocket
it